you said you fixed how many fights
hundreds of fights
hundreds of fights yeah uh and were any
one of them you fixed like title fights
were there any
big big fights or no i
fixed i fixed um
championship championship fighters
fights many times i didn't fix
championships big names people would
know about yeah
big names people would know about that
from 80s 90s
from the 90s to 2000s early 2000s
heavyweight lightweight all over but but
um
i'm trying to think of how many former
heavyweight champions do you have a
fight you fixed hypothetically do you
have a fight
you fixed that you were part of that if
the world knew about it that would be
shell-shocked
yes yeah a a few of them
i can't they're they're around and you
know when people can
we can we do like one question just one
question you don't have to ask i can try
i'm going to ask a question i'll do my
best because let our imagination have
something
too much to see if we can answer this
the one that we would be shell-shocked
was the fighter latino black or white
the one that you would be shell-shocked
both fighters were black
i mean if you would have said filipino
we figured it out but that's definitely
not gonna
and both fighters at one time have been
the heavyweight champion of the world
and you haven't mentioned their names
today no okay they're both around
they're both friends of mine and we've
given a lot of clues
if i'm a betting man a person should be
able to figure this out and these two
were in the 90s
these were in the 90s at this point of
the game i mean
people who are watching it they're
probably guessing down they're putting
their names there but again you're not
going to say who it is so this
this was a this was a you thing this was
a mop thing this was a collaboration
this was
the fix were other big names involved in
the fix or
oh no this is this is something that
that the fighters themselves fixed and
uh they knew about it yeah the my guy
calls me
beforehand and neither one of them talks
about it till today no one knows about
it it's never been written i've never
been talked about never
never never how many people know that
that fight was fixed if you were to say
there's this many people that were on
the inside two of them are no longer
with us
how many are living that were involved
in that fix that would know it
five names three names maybe five maybe
five
maybe five
if you guys are good at keeping secrets
like that now i should hire you
you shouldn't hire me yeah you should
come work let's see we want you on our
team
i want you charles yes dang that's
pretty intense
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye